well let's let's be real for a second
what do you think is going to happen to
these blue areas
when the collapse or the disarray
happens or the or the
you know you know it's a red tribe
talking point that you know oh you know
the blue areas they're all fashion
designers and accountants and there's a
totally fake economy there and these
people don't produce anything whereas
out here in steel and corn country this
is the real world
and uh you know i i i understand
the emotions behind that um that the
blue tribe often doesn't
see the red tribe virtues they don't
appreciate hard work
and diligence and you know breaking
bones and getting sweaty and all these
other things
and so you want to believe that you know
there are feet losers bug men living in
pods
um and then my books by the way start
out i think there's uh you know on the
dedication page that you know this is to
robert heinlein who taught us not to be
bug men living in pods
um but the blue areas do huge amounts of
useful things and we're not going to you
know if there were a civil war we're not
going to surround boston for a second
time and starve them out
because they export intellectual
property and they've got a port and all
of the food they ever want to buy is
going to come in from the world so
i'm not predicting a collapse and i'm
not predicting civil war
um i think a peaceful divorce would be
great i think both sides would do okay
afterwards
in a peaceful divorce um it wouldn't be
both sides
you know there's no real way to split
the country in two
but there there there could be five
regions and there could be a bunch of
different regions
you know where where where do uh you
know i mean california produces a
massive amount of food
for the country and for the world but
i'm not convinced that the farmers into
larry who are mostly trump supporting
republicans
are going to be like sure i'll give my
food to these hippie lunatics in the
cities right well
give or you know are subject to a
regulation by i mean if
conquered yeah um i don't know that
either side uh really has the manpower
to do that i think that we are going to
see if there is a great divorce which i
don't think is super likely but i hope
we do uh if there's a great divorce i
think
china comes in then well so that's the
other thing
if you look at the us revolution the u.s
revolution only succeeded because there
was a great power war going on where
england didn't have the ability to fight
us because they were busy fighting
france
and if you look at how the us always
plays divide and conquer we're always
backing one faction overseas you know
this syrian
um you know rebel group versus the other
one and so
uh you know i think china is going to uh
get old before it gets rich so they are
most dangerous for the next 10 or 20 or
30 years
but i don't think that the future of the
world is chinese but but but
if the u.s got into severe problems then
absolutely china would be funneling
money and weapons yeah and you would see
one faction in the united states side
with china
to win that would be crazed just like
the revolution man i don't i i
you know i look at these uh these
regions they've they've in this poll
where it's like you have the pacific
region the heartland the south the
northeast
there was a great book by joel guru like
30 years ago called the nine nations of
north america
yeah on this topic but i think the
northeast might be the most at risk you
know look i can look at the heartland
there's a lot of corn there i can look
at the pacific and be like california
produces a ton of food
i look at look at the south and i'm like
also lots of farmland and fertile areas
mountains impossible to take
north how could you invade them what
does the northeast have crabs
the northeast has ports i mean if you go
to whole foods in cambridge
massachusetts right now
you know where is that food coming from
i'm sure some of it is coming from
vermont but a lot of it's coming from
chile or but
let's let's say the northeast was just
you know um by itself
okay what does it have to offer for its
ports to function lumber crab
lumber yeah i mean you know i i think
that where's new hampshire gonna get
what do we expect we've got a lot of
rocks
new hampshire i think it's leading
industries are things like you know
healthcare administration
and uh you know well you know i don't
want to work in that industry i'd rather
do what i do
um but again this gets to the red tribe
belief that like
that's not real work it's all make work
and there's no reason for it to exist
and uh
i'm gonna go with sort of a chesterton
fence that you know this exists and i
assume there's a good reason for it
they're presumably delivering value to
someone
there are many jobs that should not
exist but are forced to
there's a great essay [ __ ] excuse me
uh but but bold jobs and i don't know if
you said
and i think i uh do agree with that so
so i'm not going to
contradict myself uh i thought about
this for a long time insurance salesman
no offense if you sell insurance but you
know most
for the most part people go online and
automatically get their service
mcdonald's fast food restaurants they
just replace some people with kiosks
and so what i think is happening is that
one thing i've actually i've talked
about this
for for like since i was a teenager the
the um the struggle of capitalism in a
technology technological revolution is
uh
and this is a really obvious for a lot
of people where that when you bring
when you have an industrialization a lot
of jobs get washed away
but in our current system we don't just
give people stuff the challenge there is
if one person has to work to to help the
society survive
they will not tolerate for them very
likely if other people are not working
and getting equal access to resources
right so so so long as there are people
who need to make food
giving free food to other people is
going to make people angry
in which case that's one of the biggest
challenges we have
as we move forward technologically
you'll get people saying don't take my
job away
and then when someone gets their job
taken away through no fault of their own
and then you get a government subsidy
then they're like
you're taking my tax dollars to pay them
with this potential breakup or great
reset
they will erase all of these jobs and
they are
we see fast food restaurants struggling
to hire people how long until they all
just
upgrade to kiosks many of them probably
will and and then
and then how about this i went to i was
at a i was at a
um a rest station they had an ice cream
ice cream
box and it was a little robot man and i
put i wanted a chocolate sundae with
with chocolate syrup and sprinkles
and the little robot man goes and then
hands me the little thing
we don't need a human being to do it
anymore so this great reset
i imagine is going to purge a ton of
jobs
to go off on a tangent about this job
loss um you know the the libertarian or
free market answer is you know
actually automation and steel mills is
great because it used to take 100
blacksmiths to do something and you're
sure you're upset that 99 of them are
unemployed
but they're now gonna get new jobs as
machinists and you know uh as we get rid
of the sort of uh but that's that's not
true
somebody somebody who is mining coal
can't learn to code right and and so i
agree with you and that's where i'm
going with this thesis
it was true to some decent degree that
as certain jobs went away there were
always more jobs that were brought in
but we're getting to a point where we
can automate any job that requires less
than a 70 iq and then an 80 iq and a 90
iq
and you know uh someone who happens to
be born with a 90 iq that that's no
deficit of character that's just how it
is and he's equally human being as
anyone else
but you start to get to a problem when
we can automate anything under
a 90 or 95 or 100 or 105 iq and i do
worry that we're getting to that world
now you were talking about
the anger against uh welfare and there
is a fair bit of anger but on the other
hand
we have as a society a rhetorical device
or several rhetorical devices
we have welfare for the old called
social security and the polite fiction
is you paid into that and you did
but you end up taking a lot more out of
it than you put in and we have another
plate fiction which is disability and
the the
fiction there is you can't work so a
decent society helps you and there are
some people who are truly disabled uh
there's a good article in the atlantic i
don't know like two or three years ago
talking about how disability is kind of
a different form of welfare
where if you go to the right doctor and
say the right things where there are um
unfalsifiable statements like my back
hurts then you get it
and um so you know all societies have
white lies they tell themselves and i
wonder if disability is ours to deal
with the fact that cognitive
but look things are being praised now
let's let's think about that term in the
context of
the great reset or or a great divorce
within this country
how how will people in cities get access
to food from
uh farmers if right now what we're
seeing is they're doing this
unemployment thing they've been doing it
non-stop they're doing child tax credits
now
so a lot of people who aren't working
are getting money that means
for the farmer who's growing corn or
wheat or whatever and they go to sell it
they do a lot of work they have to
you can't just snap your fingers and
make that stuff it's right it's not
that's hard work but
you don't just poke a hole in the ground
and drop a seed and it was like como or
something right the people in the cities
they're handed money and they walk to
you and they get
your labor effectively for free right
how that
i can't imagine that's sustainable yeah
the only way that actually keeps
sustaining itself is that the people
doing the work don't
know that people who aren't doing work
are are you know as long as they don't
know that's happening
but they do know what's happening yeah
yeah so i can only imagine you know
going back to that
as you mentioned the the what do you
call it a red state belief or the yeah
red state red tribe red dry belief um
i'll tell you this man i know a lot of
people live in cities
you put them in the middle of the woods
it's over so this ties into a prepping
thing
where um you know i sometimes flip
through prepping magazines when i'm at
the bookstore having a coffee which i do
you know once a week or so
or you know someone will afford me
something off of a prepping form and
people
like this idea that oh i'm gonna buy a
can of survival seeds or
my plan when the system collapses i'm
gonna bug out and i'm gonna find an
abandoned farm and i'll just start
farming and um you know speaking of my
own experience
um my wife and i have been on the farm
for about eight years and we have been
working you know hugely hard you know uh
on the order of you know all of saturday
all of sunday
weeding and chainsawing down trees and
converting pasture and stretching fences
and we've also brought in pros to help
us with some of this like you know
fencing and other stuff
and there's so much equipment and
there's so much specialized knowledge
which is why the books are so thick
where you know i learned that you know
oh and this past year i want to grow
hay so that i can feed sheep so i can
get food from that but before i can grow
hay i've got to kill off the poison ivy
which means that i need to put down 2 4
d and 360 at a certain application rate
we just to finish real quickly the idea
that you're going to wander out with a
can of survival seeds
as civilization is collapsing and you
know feed yourself is
absolutely insane homesteading is a
viable approach but you know it's a
10-year plan what what's the uh um
for what's tomatoes mm-hmm
how long out of the year do you get
viable tomatoes right
absolutely so uh you know if you plant
all of your tomatoes at once all of your
tomato harvest is gonna come in over a
course of two weeks now you can stagger
that by planting tomatoes
week one week two week three in
different batches um but even then
your tomatoes are gonna be very you know
short interval and there's not a lot of
calories in tomatoes
so uh you know again getting the
survival scenario this is fine you know
homesteading is a hobby and a lifestyle
and i'll defend it as that but it's not
um you know a way to survive the
apocalypse with no inputs there's a huge
amount of inputs of diesel fuel and
fertilizer
oh yeah yeah we uh we have uh our
tomatoes
i would say that we had four
uh um standard tomato plants and one
cherry tomato the cherry tomatoes
easy i walk outside we pick them all we
walk in they're good to go
the regular tomatoes are extremely
difficult the bugs get them yep
the uh they they a lot of rot some of
them turns black
you know and there's all sorts of
details like if you want to save the
seeds from tomatoes tomatoes are uh
tricky because there is a sort of gel
like coating on the seeds and you have
to let the seeds sit in the gel and rot
for a week or two and then wash them off
and then preserve the seeds
and this is another thing that uh you
know if you don't know this stuff you're
just gonna make an absolute
hash of it yeah yeah so um you know we
have a garden
and the funny thing is we get like
baseball bat size zucchini
and over the course of the past two
weeks it's like we can't eat all this
like we just
we set up a garden but we grew a whole
bunch all that all the tomatoes come
around the same time
yep and then we're like what are we
gonna do right make a sauce i guess you
know preservation technology is huge and
there's a whole
lot of flavors that we as humans like
because we sort of evolved in a
semi-civilized state we love smoked beef
jerky
because that's a preservation technology
we like pickles because that's a
preservation technology we're like
cheese because that's a preservation
technology
and my hint with the zucchini by the way
i peel my zucchini i shred them in a
food processor i vacuum seal them i
throw in a chest freezer
and uh then i mix that with ground
turkey and onions and make turkey
fritters all year long
now what's fascinating though is that a
lot of what you're describing is we got
modern technology like freezers and
refrigerators
so i'll tell you this man where we are
right now
we are um this this facility is going to
be
for the most part off the grid nice
meaning our water is well water
and we're getting solar and batteries
installed nice we're still on the grid
yep
but in the event of an absolute
catastrophe we're going to be able to be
fine we'll have to reduce a lot of our
energy consumption
but uh actually we'll have a decent
amount of power these batteries are
hefty men yep i i i carried like four
thousand pounds of lead acid batteries
down in my basement
without my system so i know all about it
yeah they are nifty well
well i think we're gonna have lithium
nice i'm not entirely sure i put mine in
around seven or eight years ago and i'm
going to
i'm building out the solar right now and
the second battery bank is going to be
lithium but let's let's be real man like
people in cities stacked on top of each
other they're they're not going to have
any of this
power is going to go out and the food's
going to be gone i was i was in new york
when sandy hit
mm-hmm and there were there were two
guys staying outside of a bodega with
like a two with two by fours and a
baseball bat
one person at a time and the guy said
all the refrigerator stuff is spoiled
because the power was out for a couple
weeks ago right right they were like the
cans are good everything else is spoiled
mm-hmm so you know take what you want
is awesome yeah mountain dew was fine
you know all the sodas
were fine but uh um anything perishable
gone right
so your freezers all that stuff in the
city yeah over right
and um what are those people going to do
yeah no they they are absolutely screwed
and
you're going to find them on your farm
well uh you know i do have a chapter on
firearms
well there you go right um you know
this ties back to the idea of prepping
in the power law which is the title of
one of the essays i think it's in volume
two
where uh you know how often does new
york city
lose power um you know for a week or
something it happened i think back in 76
or 78 or something hurricanes
and hurricane sandy so this is the kind
of thing it seems inconceivable
but you pull back and zoom out and
you're like no this crap happens every
30 or 40 years and you're going to live
another 30 or 40 years you're going to
see it happen again you're going to see
all these things happen this is a
lifetime
this is the craziest thing to me about
when i was like last year i'm like hey
guys pick up these you know food bins
yeah i i got to say it was mostly these
young people a lot of these lefties the
socialists are young
they don't have the worldly experience
to have dealt with these things
having seen hurricane sandy i was like
wow it would be great if i had one of
those food bins
so i remember when i was live in new
york and there i can remember what was
happening there was some concern about
another storm i went and bought
i bought two things of bottled water i
was like that's going to be important
they tell you in chicago whenever they
say there's a big storm coming you fill
up your bathtub yeah
because you know if the water goes bad
if lines break if some disaster happens
you got a bunch of water in your bathtub
that's the kind of thing people who are
older i guess learn younger people don't
but
still there is like this arrogance of of
many people live in cities like you said
they think they can grab
a can of seeds and go find a farm
somewhere right i'll tell you man
in the uh what did noam chomsky say in
the arena of violence the most brutal
guy wins and that ain't us and he was
referring to leftists
right right these people think they're
going to go to a farm where they're
going to find a guy who's been
using a gun a firearm or multiple ones
for practical purposes be it hunting or
you know or
or you know dealing with the rodents and
stuff and they're going to be able to
walk on and just
lay claim right to a already built up
and secured and maintained farm
fertilizer yeah that's what they're
going to be as fertilizers right
um you know i don't know if humans can
be fertilizer that's kind of i don't
know
i've got a chapter of composting
well we hope it doesn't come to that
honestly right right uh a lot of hungry
people though
you know so there's another thing that i
hear in prepping circles uh and it's a
feel-good phrase
you know it's not the equipment that you
have that matters it's what you know
that matters because you know
equipment can be taken from you but what
you know is a resource
and you know if if there's some guy
living in a basement uh you know
in brooklyn and he's been reading
survival forms for six years and then
the system collapse and
he comes out to my farm and wants to
share his knowledge with me for food
you know i don't need any knowledge that
this guy you know learned from endlessly
recycled blog posts
um you know there's oh gosh
there's some ancient greek words for
different kinds of knowledge uh
technique and medicine or something
um but to really really know something
you've got to do and you've got to do it
ahead of time and you're absolutely
doing this with your tomatoes and your
chicken so if you lost power
you've already practiced it so that's
real knowledge it's not something you
want
you want we got it we got a couple
mulberry trees mm-hmm and so we made
mulberry jam
we made uh uh we mixed wine berry and
mulberry wild bay that was actually
really i'm not a big fan of mulberries
oh i love them but when you mix some
when i mix them with the wine berries is
really good
and the wine berries alone i think the
combination but anyway digress
do you know how many calories you
probably do are in 10 mulberries uh i'm
guessing that it rounds to zero like ten
six okay all right six yeah ian nailed
it last time he's like six i'm like how
did you know that
but ten wow that's a
small handful of berries you're gonna
shove in your mouth six calories
right you will not there's there's no
amount of mulberry you're gonna eat to
sustain yourself
for even a few hours right and so you
know naturally occurring fruits and
stuff people don't realize
uh i'll tell you this story and this
this plays into exactly what i'm saying
i had friends during occupy wall street
got granted farmland mm-hmm
how long do you think let me ask you how
long do you think they last they made it
so so they went out there and tried to
say that they sent me great they said
we we don't want to be on the grid we're
tired of contributing to this this this
machine of pollution and climate change
so we're going to the farm to live
sustainably
three days a week two weeks okay you
know i'm impressed most people say like
a couple months no
no a few days you didn't even give them
the benefit of the doubt uh two weeks
okay you know what they realized i asked
my friend and she was like
i was like why'd you come back she was
like because i'd wake up at 6am to work
go to bed at
midnight yep and i'm like yeah what did
you think farming was
when when you are actually trying to
sustain yourself you
never stop working right right and and
this gets into
you know people have said you know to me
oh you know if we had a collapse i bet
you'd love it you know
like no man uh right now it's a very
very hard hobby that i do on the
weekends
with lots of diesel fuel coming in
outside
if that diesel fuel went away and you
know i tried to make a producer gas
still using old fema plans and started
logging trees
to make producer gas to do stuff you
know that
is better than starving to death but uh
that's hard but you know what i did this
morning
i went out and i grabbed some fresh
jalapenos
and a poblano and some some cherry
tomatoes
and then i i went to the chicken coop
and i got a couple eggs and so uh one of
our chickens is i guess she's young so
she's doing double eggs
like they're twice as big they're
massive right and uh
i would say to be fair 99 of my
breakfast was completely
home-grown yeah but i threw in some
garlic powder and and people like to say
you know and it's so much healthier i'm
not sure it is healthier but man it's so
much more satisfying isn't it that's
just amazing we're like this all came
from you know to be honest
um i'm not a big fan of like throwing
peppers
like if i went to a restaurant i ordered
i'd be like give me the bacon and the
eggs with
your cheese on top but today i had
cherry tomatoes with
fresh cut jalapenos poblano on eggs and
it tasted so good nice nice
you know that is one of the most
satisfying things and we've done all
sorts of stuff
um you know we've made corn fritters
we've uh
uh made maple uh syrup creme brulee from
maple trees that we've tapped and i boil
down the sap and make my own maple syrup
um i i i push back on homesteaders who
say everything tastes better like no you
know some food at you know whole foods
in the supermarket tastes really good
the one thing that uh comes from the
farm that's just absolutely amazing is
homemade bacon
and you know i'm not gonna say it's ten
percent better it's 20 better homemade
bacon is like
literally ten times better like you just
don't want store made stuff
we've got farms around here uh-huh and
so we we have gotten fresh
and it is indescribable yeah right like
i i don't even want the store-bought
stuff right right i mean
it's not the same yeah it's a pale
imitation it's like turkey bacon or
something it's like turkey bacon
and if i can plug my own book again oh
yeah i've got tons of details on how to
make your own bacon from scratch and you
can do it even living on the suburbs i
started scratching
is it is it does it is it just take pig
it does yeah i mean the ingredients say
you know uh you need you know salt salt
man um
and you need uh and you need pig and you
know for pig see page 458
um but uh you can practice a bunch of
the stuff living in the suburbs you can
buy a whole pork belly from the butcher
and do it
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you